so i'm turning on
the microphone i guess we are live
streaming this is the
work session for house bill
1368 in legislative administration
we have a limited
audience and a limited committee
but we certainly can
can have
a discussion on
where the
where the responsibility lies with the
legislative committee
dealing with uh house bill 1368
from from the lowest possible bar
are charges to decide whether
the legislation is worthy of of
going forward
in the next term or whether we believe
it's
it's reached its
usefulness and will and will terminate
here
doesn't mean that future legislation
won't however be or the same legislation
be
resubmitted in september
but um
what i would like to do this is not a
hearing i want to make that clear
this is a work session so
and it's meant for
the committee members to
discuss amongst ourselves and and
pull it apart and decide ultimately
whether the legislation should go
forward or
or
be recommended to to terminate
um
i'm going to run this
very informally and
and let everyone
talk the way they want to from the
committee
if there are questions that you
have
committee members
that you would like to address
to
the member of the ethics committee that
is also in the room um
i'm going to allow that um
i wouldn't have
had there been additional committee
members but um
commit additional people in the in the
room but
i'm going to try to do this as
informally as possible and if anybody
um
wants to go from there we certainly can
my goal just
just to set the table a little bit
my goal is to
with legislation on conflict of interest
and and recusal
um
is always to create something so simple
that any any member
um
who listens to
a piece of legislation
can in their own mind
without consulting their family attorney
or
anyone else around them make the
determination
fairly rapidly whether this is
rises to the level of a conflict of
interest and whether they should recuse
themselves from
from the debate and or from the vote
i don't
i don't want this to get to the point
where it rises to a complaint and
therefore it's something that the ethics
committee has to deal with
in the past we've seen cases i believe
where
the ethics committee has acted on
complaints
and
and the confusion of the legislat the
existing rules and regulations were such
that
um
a shrug of the shoulders and and a slap
on the wrist was um put forth just
because
we couldn't understand the rules or we
thought we were on the right side of the
rules and therefore
um
you know it was not acted upon i
i think
we should be able to create
i'm a black and white guy anyway um
and i would rather er on the side of
recusal than not
but that may be me so um with that i'm
that with that background of
of what i'm looking for as just a member
of this work session
um maybe everyone else would want to
chime in of what they're looking for
and and what
problems or
um
or pieces of the legislation they
particularly enjoy
or or want to see removed i think all of
that would be helpful
so with that i'm pretty much going to
just step down as chair and be
a work session uh participant
anyone want to go
i think you do so you can stream
so the questions that i have whenever i
take a look at bills especially ethics
bills is i always go back to the
underlying definitions of what i'm doing
because in order to
rewrite something i need to understand
what the terms mean or how they're
defined to determine whether or not they
are correctly put in any proposed
legislation like in this one
and when i first read the bill i had a
question as to how
household member was defined because
it's referenced throughout this
amendment um
they we talk about conflict of interest
and they talk about financial and
non-financial but then almost every
other paragraph that's amended here one
a one b and five
talks about the legislator or
legislators household member
so i went back to the definition of a
household member
and the definition of a household member
was a little bit
confusing to me and probably needed to
be
looked at a little closer
in today's day and age a lot of folks
that contribute
to daily expenses
um
of a household doesn't necessarily have
to be living in that household
so you can have a divorced couple
or a customer that is separated
and they're not necessarily domiciled
in the same household anymore
but yet they contribute to the daily
living
so household member
to me
i would remove
living in the same domicile
as the same legislator a legislative
employee and take that first part of the
test
out of it
and i would have and as i put before
with a draft amendment
2106h to this
that a household member shall mean any
person
who shares a common economic interest in
the expense of
daily living of a legislator a
legislative employee including but not
limited to spouse child or parent
i think that's more in tune with what we
have because you're limited
you're limited currently that you have
to live in that household even though
you're contributing to the daily
expenses
and so to me for purposes of conflict of
interest it needed to be expanded a bit
so i dropped the domicile first part of
the test that was the first thing
because to be mentioned throughout this
entire bill
i thought was
an important thing to go back and look
at
and so it includes
people that are not necessarily living
in the same household and you know and
it can be a problem because when you say
household member a lot of people may
think
that you have to be in the household and
that's why the domicile was there so to
remove it
i think is a big step in including
people to have them think about well
geez could i be considered a household
member so then the next thing is and i
didn't address this
do you want to have a household member
or does it need to be another word to
make people
you know
look at it should it be family member
should it be
whatever it is i don't know but to just
kind of go with what was in here
if i changed the household member i felt
much better about including more people
to look at whether or not they had a
conflict or not so that's what i did
that was my one of my things and and
whether or not whether or not we pass
this legislation i mean recommend this
legislation to be brought forward again
i think that
maybe a little bit more in scope needs
to be looked at just other than the
financial and the non-financial interest
um
but i mean i wasn't a member of that
committee and i don't think we really
went into this when we heard
that he we had the hearing i mean at the
time you know i have to be honest i
didn't go back to look at the
definitions of everything until i read
it again
we knew it probably was going to be
retained to look at it interim study and
that's when i really kind of went into
this thing
so that's all i have to say
well
while you're on the household member
definition
um
did you do any consideration or any
thought about the the common economic
interest piece that phrase
in there because i'm not sure
that average legislator
um sitting in his
seat in reptile would say common
economic interest
what the heck is that
which number is that in greg that uh
that's right in definition 14b
one definition oh you're talking about
going looking at the definitions of the
whole the statute
the current statute okay not the bill
itself okay that's where that same
domicile comes from that same line
it says a common economic interest
i can see
people saying
i need it i need a
definition of that
because down below
it talks about a financial interest
exists but it doesn't talk any and a
non-financial personal interest exists
well i think the way i read that was
when they share an economic interest in
the sentence in the expenses of daily
living
that's how i had defined economic
interest at the expenses of daily living
so
i didn't look to change that because i i
kind of equated it to be the expenses of
daily living so is economic the same as
financial
i think might be
a good question i don't know but in
terms of the consistency here so it
would seem to me that that household
member definition
change economic interest to financial
interest
well but we also talk about
non-financial interest
so
so do we not use that household member
definition when it when it comes to a
non-household non-economic personal
interest i think it could
i know but this is the part that you can
see
where someone has to make that decision
um if there's not common language used
in
throughout the definitions
so then are you thinking
i did not think it was and you know you
can get in this rabbit hole and not get
out of the rabbit hole and i and we're
probably pretty deep into the rabbit
hole right about now so i'm thinking
household interest shall mean any person
who shares
an interest
you've got me or maybe jesus shares the
expenses of daily living or taking the
whole thing i mean i don't know or even
just uses the same language
and so
it would say the household
house of representative senator who
shares a financial interest or a
non-financial personal interest correct
so uses the same language rather than
creating this economic interest yep i
agree
yep
another amendment to the amendment
yes
maybe this is a good time to ask
whether
um mr lambert could
chime in whether that is a was
considered and not considered if you
want to jump up to the
we won't call it the witness table we'll
just call it the
come closer to the
to the
work
this ever conversation issue of conflict
of interest has been the most
complicated
um part of this from the beginning it's
gone through several changes
both in terms of definitions and all and
scope
and also the various forms
so yes that's been talked about for a
long time
the requirement was spouse period
so this was expanded
already
um
and
financial interest also uses the
term household member in its definition
so i mean we have three
entities here the guidelines and two
statutes which all have pretty much
overlapping definitions in some case
in some cases
so not just overlapping sometimes
they're completely different words maybe
describing the same thing
but
so on page 26 of the booklet in 14b
special interest is defined and then
that's broken down to what you were just
saying mr chairman the financial
interest and a non-financial personal
interest
26.
it's the same 14b one definitions that
we've been talking about
okay i'm just pulling it off the statute
and it seems that using that special
interest definition
when the legislation was done
the phrase distinct from and greater
than the interests of the public at
large were
deleted or omitted
but i don't want to jump into that
subject until we get off of this one of
whether
a common economic interest is the same
as
a financial interest
and if that's the case why
not use the financial interest language
and and does the household member not
also have a non-financial personal
interest they do
but but it's not mentioned in the
household member definition
well that's true
and that's this is where the confusion
lies for that person that's trying to
that's not an attorney that's trying to
figure out for themselves do i have a a
conflict of interest with this piece of
legislation when you start
getting the definitions and this is the
key the definitions well devil is in the
details right um
the definitions that's would be the
first place that i would go as a
legislator to determine whether i have a
conflict
i would read that household member and
say a common economic interest oh great
it's
it's a non-economic interest that i'm
that i'm worried about so therefore i'm
fine well until you read down below
and it says
non-financial exists and and now i'm
now i'm confused and i don't know
whether to recuse myself or not
well
generally there would be no
you would not have to um
recuse yourself
you would the question is disclosure
and that's
the other area where
because see
you can't get to that point unless you
have the definitions defined precisely
right and so what greg is absolutely
correct common economic interests should
be
financial or non-financial interest
there's no question that's one thing
that has to happen but we really can't
we really can't just say
that they live in the same domicile
that
can't be if you're going to women
with non-financial interests you see i
do
so that's where
and i feel like we're but i feel like
we're nitpicking and i'm and i'm not
trying to be that i'm trying to get to
the point where we're using the same
language in every area
for that simple
purpose of letting the legislator decide
for themselves not having to go to you
and ask if there's a
if they have a problem that's that's my
bottom line is how do they how do they
decide for themselves
well i know that when members come to me
about their financial disclosure forms
like a lot of them would
they were confused about it but they're
happy that there's some sort of line
drawn where in the domicile
is stated because they'll say things
such as well i don't know what my kids
interests are
or you know i have no control over what
they do and what i have to file an
amended form every time they do
something
that changes their economic interests so
that's the kind of
issue
in a practical sense yeah
i can see i can see that but also in the
case that um that representative ruler
brought up
what if what if you are
still
still controlling the economic interests
of your family
um
but from another location you are a
divorce parent or something like that
you know certainly
that would
be an issue if yes
um so
even within just that one little
phrase
we've got two
diametrically opposed situations
one you would one you wouldn't
so
but it doesn't help when you're using
different
phraseology to describe the same
different units of measurement yeah
different using units of measure i like
that
um
so at any rate i
i don't know how we resolve
i don't know i think
i think also the other thing as i'm
sitting here really reading this again
for probably the 100th time
um on the bill itself under
and that's
they changed financial and non-financial
um
to eliminate the last sentence here
substantially greater than the benefit
or detriment would be through a business
client so why is that in special
interest
versus
so why would we have special
financial interest in a non-financial
interest to be a different burden or a
different test
then we have a special interest
so you're pulling back the old language
from financial and non-financial and
seeking it back in special interest
and which by the way
you know
it's just a mess
and it also has household members doing
it
it needs to be redefined
for many years conflict of interest was
defined as financial interest period
and it is in many states still it's they
ignore
the non-financial it was the
recommendations of the
uh study commission that changed that in
2000 2014 and it was passed in 15 by
okay legislature
um did was that done for a
for a specific instance or or was it
just
looking at other
they were looking at everything states
and the thought was that
right along the thought has been that
most legislators want to conform with
these provisions but a lot of cases they
don't understand them because they're
complicated
so
the commission looked long and hard at
conflict of interest and there was a
discussion about requiring recusal
um that was not only about two members
agreed with that others were very
strongly opposed to requiring recusal
so um
instead they then focused on uh
strengthening the conflict of interest
to add more to it such as the non-uh
financial personal interest
um
and
that's when
they moved
financial interest into this new term
special interest that was a creation of
the study a recommendation of the study
commission
um
so that now this bill would reverse that
in a sense because you're taking
out financial interest and non-financial
personal interest from the definition of
special interest and putting it under
conflict of interest
where it used to be
because i think that
representative gordon
wanted to have a term
that would define when you needed to
recuse
ah
but nowhere did we see in here just
um disclosure is
there there's no table for saying and in
these
circumstances you disclose and in these
circumstances you
you recuse and those are the two options
right i mean that
there's not a third that i that isn't
also mentioned no okay so they bulked up
the disclosure by adding non-financial
but also requiring verbal disclosure
so that
and that applies to the
broader definition of
when you have a
conflict of interest
for example the retirement system if a
legislator or household member is in the
retirement system and you disclose that
on your financial disclosure form
and a bill comes along that affects all
members of the of the retirement system
equally
you don't have to file another form you
don't have to file the declaration of
intent form but you do
have to
make a verbal disclosure at certain
points when you're engaging in in
advocacy
that that was the idea that then because
the thought was well these forms just
get you know filed away somewhere no one
knows
if you're
or another example if you're a landlord
and you're testifying on a bill that
helps the landlord side of the landlord
tenant
issue
maybe you file some form somewhere but
it's not really readily known when
you're testifying so in the from
the result of this change you need to
say yes
i'm a landlord and then you can make
your
argument
go
so
the way the bill reads now
um
a financial interest exists for a
legislator
could stand to gain or lose anything of
material values as a result of the
official capacity would that require
that legislator
who has a financial interest as a member
of a union or the state employee against
pension
what would they be required to do would
they be have to recuse or would they
have to just disclose disclose
and how does it where does how would the
person that's reading that definition
know that they would be disclosing once
you're entering so if they have it
exactly and if they so if they have
something that they are
going to gain
financially
why shouldn't they choose
well right now they're not required to
but ideally that's a policy decision
that
for
i don't i didn't redisclose anywhere in
any of these did you ever see anywhere
that that that disclosure was a
different yeah it's in the guidelines
page
begins on page 7
and particularly on 12
which is the conflict of interest
procedure
part six of the guidelines
did you bring extras of those
perfect
yeah mine's in the car too
thanks very much
no pun intended
associated with a compliant procedure
and
i guess
i still come back true to your question
claire what what good does that do us um
because recusal was discussed
i mean there were
gary richardson has been an attorney for
many years and
any attorney knows that you know you
don't disclose anything you recuse from
a case if you have some sort of conflict
of interest
but that's always been
i mean you could go back to the
beginning when
former senator and congressman charlie
bass established this
committee
they talked about recusal then a little
bit but they were felt fortunate to get
past what got passed it took many years
to have an ethics committee
because the thought was that this is a
citizens legislature
where people have
not paid they have jobs and interests of
their own and many times constituents
the argument is constituents are voting
for people because of their expertise in
a certain area perhaps right you know in
agricultural areas of the state it's
important to have
people represent the interests of
farmers and
logging interests or whatever and
so
that's why it was based on disclosure
most of the time
and when i say most of the time because
it's other
part of the guidelines the prohibited
activities
and that that
is something you can look at too which
is what
the two
aspects of this came
together bumped together in the
complaint two of our complaints that you
have
one against former senator bragdon and
one against representative late
representative lay
because
we have always been careful in any sort
of orientation or continuing education
to say
most of our
guidelines require
disclosure but that's not always
a solution the remedy to
you having a financial interest there
are some
circumstances which are laid out in the
prohibited activity section where you
can't
participate in disclosure would not
solve that
what exactly what can you give me an
example of that
and that's i think representative hill
was referring to that the committee
would
didn't go forward with any sort of
serious sanctions in those cases because
representative lay
argued that he made disclosures that he
was
president of the union if that's what he
was president
and um he thought that's all he had to
do but
um if you look into the prohibited
activity section which is i keep
having to refer you to these things but
in four
and um
yes
uh
page four
in fact that first paragraph
i was added by the study commission to
clarify that there are some
circumstances where disclosure does not
you can read it yourself excuse or
absolve
from compliance with the prohibited
activities
so legislators shall not solicit accept
or agree to accept anything of value
from other persons
knowing or believing they may be
wanting to influence
you or the legislation
um you know in all those circumstances
or d
um if you were
um employed by someone who was
interested in legislation you can't
introduce legislation or testify
if you were receiving something of value
such as a salary from that entity
it's getting more complicated right now
yeah so it not only becomes complicated
it it's circular
there is no end point at any of this
there's no
lines that i have with if you have a
and bright
financial interest
either you or somebody in your household
would like to have it no longer living
there
um has a financial interest
they can disclose that when they fill
out the form before this one interact
this one and i forget when it is
but i'm not sure
that we should have those folks voting
on legislation that would directly
benefit their purse and that's the
problem and now
two farmers coming to testify
that we need this pesticide or we don't
need this pesticide and this would help
them
that's a little bit different
than them coming to testify on
legislation to prohibit a pesticide or
not to prepare the pesticide
that's not a direct financial interest
even though they're a farmer
and there's legislation coming forward
i'm not sure that that's in the
prohibited activities or not
if they are introducing something
without defaulting
i would want to as a legislative member
of a committee that's listening to that
i would want to know what they know
about this
so
i mean i certainly don't want to be
critical but i guess i am
um so
i guess
i don't know i don't know
with any of this i don't like being at
the circle well there's no bright line
that's been the problem
the commission's tried to do that but it
didn't what we're talking about is
strengthening the guidelines
considerably and i just think it's not
my job to talk about the politics of it
but i don't think there's ever been
support
people thought there was support
does this does this um brighten the line
that the legislation
in what areas in what specifically
what
i
i would think in
eliminating that uh
distinction from greater than the
interests of the public at large that
may be one example of
of
clearing up the haze
but it's not taken out of special
interest
circular argument again my circle no uh
it it's it's crossed out under special
interests is that what you said yeah
but but it is in
where right here
it's in special it's in the bottom
substantially greater than the benefit
of different but we're true
isn't that what we're talking about
it's not
this is different substantially it is a
little bit different but that's very
this is very confusing you think it's
not about
it doesn't say
you know
this is
you you know you
you're out
are are these um in any way
were these
um developed
in-house specifically
or or was there
um
a review of what other states are doing
are we did we try to recreate the wheel
or did we use
what works other places or not for this
bill or over the years um
well both how's that um it
i guess i was thinking when i asked the
question in the in the 2014 study
committee which did did we go out and
look at they did i was not the staff
person i was there but um pam smarling
whom you remember you did a great job
doing that getting all other states
that's what you were talking about jen
that your report came from no yes the
document like the 50 state reviews yes
okay and i updated that for the ethics
committee for and for chairman gordon's
bill to see if anything had changed from
ncsl
i thought you had a comment nope
i still think we are
almost
i i think i can almost go to the
to the point of saying we're making it
worse by adding additional
or changing adding additional con
definitions by using new language
instead of using the old language it and
it doesn't seem that
we are
giving
you know expanding this ethics booklet
doesn't
doesn't make it clearer for the average
legislator as far as i can see um
we had a situation the other day i was
talking with a an existing legislator
who said he
was a was a substitute in ways and means
and when he got there he found that the
bill one of the bills that they were
executing
he had a conflict with
but he said
not having my ethics book with me
and he wouldn't have had time had he had
it to go through and know whether
he should have disclosed and or refused
and then
this is where maybe a rules change needs
to be made so that he could say i'm
sorry i have to recuse
but
he was inside that 24-hour period and he
wouldn't be able to remove himself from
that executive session
and have a new person come in that
didn't have a an issue with it so
there's
this has tentacles i guess is my point
um we need
from from one
set of facts we need to keep changing
something else down the road as it gets
influenced there's many moving parts
yeah
yeah well we tried to help a little i
hope we did with interpreter ruling
2016-5 which is in on page 64 of the
booklet and was at the time published in
the calendar
calendars and also is on the website
um because
including in that at the end there are
some hypotheticals
would it ever be possible
mr lambert to have something as simple
as a decision tree or
you know it
you know is are we talking about your
spouse all right yes okay are we talking
about a job that your spouse has that
you know
create that does this yes so that
sort of
the simpleton legislator can just go
down through and say okay here i have to
disclose that
was that ever discussed no
that's a good idea
then you could laminate it and hand it
to the legislators and
rather than say well you know on page 65
there's something that's close to what
i'm talking about that um
this guy did do that
well you know
if you look at page 68
there are
several examples actually
and they do say
declaration of intent required yes
verbal disclosure required yes so they
give certain
examples
kind of like what would write
yep probably should put that on sorry
kind of like what greg's talking about
that um you know there are some
but it doesn't
when do you have recusal
well that's what chairman gordon i
remember saying to you
if you read through
this there's no place that says you must
you must recuse
and it's been up to the committee
through
some interpretations and some complaints
to
establish some criteria for that right
and once again it would go back to the
prohibited activity section because you
can't
you can't have a lobbyist and give you
money
and or something to put in the
legislation i mean if you disclose that
you know still it's it's a crime
beyond the ethics materials even
under criminal law i would assume but
that's why
the committee that's what that's what
led to this because the committee felt
there should be clearer and also
statutory not only based on the
committee's interpretation as they
applied
the statute and guidelines to a case
as they did twice
so so
ned tried to put in this legislation
recusal i don't see that word anywhere
in here
oh yes i do
14 c colon 4 a recusal for conflicts of
interest
shall recuse himself
and and again then we get into okay an
official legislative activity special
interest be one
where is that
i know but where's the official
we don't define official yeah we do i
think it's in the guidelines
proper
uh official business means official
so i like that
recusal portion of it
but i think that the conflict of
interest
is
kind of wishy-washy
and we need to kind of shore up some of
the definitions to comply with what
financial and non-financial and special
interests
really mean
and whether or not
they require recusal
i think i actually like 14c for a
as a
as a piece
yes
it's it's simple yeah it gives you four
examples yes
and when you need to recoup
whether or not
nonprofit or for profit
right
yup i like it
that i like
but but the special the conflict of
interesting piece of it
under
is a little confusing and i i got that
and i think the household member and
they also have the word
um
[Music]
in the household members economic common
economic interest so
that would almost have to be changed
under the definition of capital not only
economic interest now they've got
the word is receiving remuneration
so we've got another
word for the same
thing under the first part of it under
receiving renewal under roman two yeah
roman two reasons is receiving from an
employer i'm in remuneration yeah which
has a special interest in the official
legislative activity
is is that defined anywhere
i don't see it i don't know
i'm sorry i didn't hear that
remuneration if you have it
if you have which is roman numeral two
under the conflict of interest refusal
so it would seem like we've got you
gotta turn on your microphone
so it seemed like we agreed that there's
some good things
in this bill to move forward
with some changes
is that
or we kind of no i i
think so so yes
so yes there are pieces that we like
this is my
there are pieces in here that make sense
yes but when you
are adding language to 65 pages
are you really moving the ball forward
to make it and are you
the legislators it still comes back to
me
that
there's two and i'm not accusing
um
ned gordon of doing this but
but are you
putting all of this in language in order
to use it when's when a complaint is
made after the fact
you know and actually and be able to use
it to say see this is where you went
wrong
or
i would prefer
to prevent such activity yes the old
and be able to have someone
without having
this
on their person 24 7 have someone be
able to say
i i think i know where the clear line
lies for
my family members
what things i can vote on what i can't
and and what things
require just disclosing and what thing i
although
i have to agree i think with claire that
disclosing
is
to the to
for me to the general public
disclosing means nothing
um you're either
and and for the same reason i've never
understood if your benefit is is any
greater than anyone else in your group
if it's
a benefit to you then it's a problem as
far as i'm concerned right and i would
rather err on the side of recusal than
the side of disclosure and
i don't
i don't think the public
for the purpose that i don't think the
public looks at
disclosure as being
your absolution
that that
and i'll grant you that that just may be
my personal view no that's my view
i i i think disclosure without having to
recuse you may you may still want to
fill out the form the disclosure form
when you're filling out the forms for
the when you are coming into the house
but that doesn't give you a pass to vote
on things if you have a special interest
financial or otherwise correct
to vote on legislation so that almost
requires recusal
so you know maybe
maybe i'm thinking too much about it but
i i just have more questions now that
i've come in here today
than
i thought i had
so
that happens a lot it with me it does
yeah
actually probably our
freshman
legislator or
almost not freshman legislator
if we've dealt with this stuff for years
it may be more important for us to
know your view
is this
overwhelming for
being handed a booklet and told
these are your new ethics and this is
when you do or don't
i've always heard on the side of
um
i don't want to be involved in something
that i shouldn't be
what what's the
what do you get from all of the
instruction and all of the guidance that
you've received
as to the state of when you disclose
when you
recuse is there
do you have a or are you just
puzzled beyond include and include this
conversation here today i don't know
yeah did we help you at all did this
help does this make it more confusing or
how how do you feel about this
well i think that it brought up some
issues that need to be looked into yeah
um
in a previous conversation
it was said that we need to bring the
language down to
a level where everybody gets it
and um
you know there was even some bills that
came up this past year that i asked my
chairman you know should i recuse
because again i'd rather fall on
the side of
safety
and being above board than
to just
you know wing it yeah
it um
were you given
it's been a while since any of us were
had gone through orientation
um i'm not even sure
are you giving the orientation
conversation or usually been part of it
i didn't last time but but chairman
gordon did
for the house and on the senate side he
did it with rick lehman oh okay
um
well both
both being attorneys um
you know you're getting
you're getting the um
that i don't know if it's even the
client attorney
conversation you know don't answer that
you know it's it's
i'm i'm wondering whether the
instruction that you're getting that
comes from this book
is
suitable for you to be able to make
decisions
well if we outgoing to me and asking if
we went by just the book alone
it's already been said that there's no
fine line to recuse
so
if they're teaching from the book
recusal wouldn't even come up right in
the teaching correct
that's how i understand it
we find that surprising
i
i do yeah i think most people the
general public would find that
surprising as well all you have to do is
announce and then it's okay to go vote
and
that i think is the problem that we're
trying to
eliminate
so does that mean
um does that
so where do we go from here we can do
this all day long um do we
do we
look over the summer for things that
and continue to talk to
and read the
50 other states and find things that we
think should be in here
or do we simply jump over the
low bar and say
the legislation
should go forward
or do we
what's the what's the will of the work
session i don't know that we should say
the legislation should go forward
study
should be done
on
ethics
definitions
and recusal
another study is similar to 2014 or well
we have to have somebody i mean what is
it that the folks put together here how
did that come out come about was it
because of just the ethics committee do
you need a study or do you need just the
ethics committee revisiting the issues
that we've brought up today with
definitions and adding we know we have
recusal in here which is good is this
bill the product of the ethics committee
or is it just ned's
i i don't know he he certainly kept them
in the loop and talked about it at the
committee meetings
i don't recall that there was never a
vote endorsing it that i can recall
okay but
they did seem to be in support of it i
know that representative wall is on it
and i don't know why senator carson or
senator
rosenwald aren't but i they were asked
maybe things happened too quickly or
something but they seem to be in support
of it
it's kind of an odd committee anyway
it's not uh
it's not a statutory committee
it's sort of i think it is yeah it is so
it's not a standing committee it's a
statutory committee and it is
but the membership seems to
remain
pretty constant um there's actually uh
uh it's almost a commission too right
there's non-legislation three public
members
it it's
i i think it's unique
um but i don't know
um
i don't think that really changes how we
are looking at
the bill before us right
i think i think
the idea of recusal is good but even in
the recusal section of the bill this
definitions that have to come in
would be defined
remuneration even with the household
definition the household definition in
in statute currently needs to remove the
common economic interest because we
don't know what that is and it's not
defined anywhere we can imagine what it
is
and we also have to
really sure up
whether or not we have a a
a special interest
or if we have a non-financial or
financial interest
those help to be all defined and only
once those are all defined can you go
back and decide whether or not what
you're going to do with this ethics book
as to whether or not
you're going to have a recusal section
in this book which i think they need
and so
that's my take on it whether it's done
with a commission whether it's done by
the committee the ethics committee
that's currently in place
or whether it's done by ned gordon cindy
rosenwald sharing constant and janet
wall i don't know but we here sitting
the four of us
this isn't it
but there's also in this book
this is the charge of the evidence
committee right yes create this book and
policies right and policies right by
their child but
but this bill
is putting it into statute
correct which is part of this booklet
it's in all the statutes right
but even if we pass this as as it stands
it still needs to get into this book by
the ethics committee
they they are the ones that take and put
the statute into this book well clearly
that's true but if we give them language
that's going to be statute
language
they're not going to be able to fix that
and comply with all the other issues
that we have
so even if we pass this bill we've not
done
justice to editing this book
just a thought well if you amended the
two statutes we would change them in
here to reflect what's current
so if we change the definitions and and
yeah um
in statute it would it would drive
yes we will be correct
now one place you could have less volume
here is if we remove the procedural
rules which only are really come into
play for a complaint
but we was always thought everything
should be in this booklet
even though it does make it longer
that important to the other committee
you know um
as a side note whenever i ask someone a
doe
a question and then they say it's on the
website um
just because it's on the website doesn't
mean i can find it and doesn't mean that
you know it doesn't absolve you of the
responsibility of telling me what the
answer to my question is i mean
you know it used to be a cartoon
and the fella said at one point a point
in every direction is the same as no
point at all um
it's
it's true
putting it in the book doesn't
help if it serves to intimidate someone
from sitting down and reading whatever
68 pages
maybe we should have a second
publication that would be a shorter
version of
yeah the cliff notes yeah
um otherwise we're going to get close to
uh
you know having the manual of
ethics over here
um
and i don't i you know i still want
in my in my perfect world i want a
little laminated card that tells
somebody yeah you've gotta
you've gotta not
you gotta stay clear of this issue and i
it's hard we need to create an app for
that so as i see it there are one two
three four five six definitions that
need to be looked at and revised
household number household has to be
revised
um common economic interest
which is in the household definition
remuneration right or yeah financial
interest maybe not defined remuneration
it just may be
it needs to be using
well but it may just be eliminated and
use the existing
could use could yeah
so either define or eliminate it right
okay
uh so financial and non-financial if if
you're going to go with what's in this
bill now
that's okay
but this bill is not going to be going
forward because there's all these other
things
and special interests remove the greater
benefit language
so we've got household
which
removes domicile
which economic interest is defined
um
or changed to financial or non-financial
interest
right
uh then financial non-financial
remuneration either define it or remove
it or change it and special interest
remove the greater benefit because i
don't think special interest putting
that language in is helpful
and currently it would add substantially
greater
benefit
i'm speaking for me i don't like that
one i don't like it at all at all to
generals if it's your how are you gonna
know
what's it what we don't we don't
actually to one
and you know and so quite frankly
if we're gonna have that language
thank baba
we want to make things work
we can do it
you can call me
well you know
um if as soon as you are getting a
benefit it doesn't matter whether it's
benefit is greater or less than someone
else's it's you're getting a benefit
that's
that's my
upbringing
there's always going to be an issue of
drawing in the line though for example
yeah a bill that affects the property
tax
or
well with the business taxes yes
or money going back to municipalities or
something like that correct there should
be
exceptions or something along those
lines because there are bills uh look
look at last year when we had the silly
omnibus bills um
it's possible that there's one little
thing in there and you're
now not able to vote on the entire you
know 32 sections of a bill
i don't
how
how has that ever hit
i mean
it's always just been handled by
disclosure yes and the idea that so many
people are affected by the property tax
and still substantial peoples affected
by the bet and bpt
or the real estate transfer attacks
that
unless it affects you more than others
in that group
disclosure on the financial disclosure
form and making the verbal disclosure at
certain points is enough
but that takes away the the idea of um
coalition in this state retirement
system
right i mean that's the that's the
trade-off
currently you could vote on that unless
it affected you more than other members
of the retirement system
but not under not under this bill
and how was that quantified is it on a
percentage basis
because
you know
are you using a yardstick or a meter
stick it's the same well
to a certain extent
you can make the argument this is how
silly it gets you can make the argument
that if you retire at 55
you have a greater benefit than the
person that retires at 65. so you know
where where is your
where's the thermometer and where's the
level and how do you get that
information in order to make that
determination so you see
where we're
we're in the weeds of it now where we
didn't want to be correct and you know
we do need exceptions i got i got the
bep the property tax i got all that
otherwise we would no legislator would
be able to vote on the budget it
wouldn't be a quorum and so there we go
so you know we have a problem with that
so we do need exceptions
but not when you have
um
a financial interest
in
you know with the household with the
financial the non-finding all of that
stuff and there needs to be recusal
i agree with with ned gordon and janet
wall on that bill i agree there needs to
be and i because i think the people of
our state thinks that there is
i do i think they think that there's
recusal you're not voting on that so
this is a little bit concerning to them
i would imagine well i get calls from
the public all the time wondering if
they should file a complaint and so what
i do is i lead them to the provisions
on their website and when they they
because they have a much different
concept of conflict of interest than
sure is reality yeah and so they're
disappointed when they hear
how limited the definition is and so
that's been going on for 30 years
well right you know well perception is
reality right yeah that
that ten that
the reason that or the explanation that
you're hearing from these people saying
that they're disappointed
that's what leads them to lump
legislators
whether the state or federal in that
they're they're all in it they're all
crooked they're all you know and that's
what
that's what i would like to take a
starter line i think yes
and i think the ethics booklet was a
start but i think that you know the four
of us sitting here
chatting is like
what's happening yeah yeah
so
again i i'll ask the question where do
we go from here what um sounds like
you're looking forward and we what are
our options again
recommend or not recommend recommend
future legislation
yeah we do this
that this is um
that the committee recommends for future
legislation
but we also can include
suggestions for that future legislation
which is our definitions
and exceptions
and and somewhere
we've got to have a conversation or have
a
how do we resolve the issue
that
rich just brought up
where is that balancing point when
you've got
um
people we need we need people to vote on
the budget
yep but we believe
that versus quorum
we believe that it's not right for
someone to vote on a cost of living
increase on the pension so
how do you
how do you do one and not affect the
other
i don't i i'd be happy to
entertain
thoughts on i think i think like i said
i don't think these four people sitting
here at the same table
well it
it should be
actually
i get it we've got legislation but i
think that the committee the commission
whatever it is that we have that's
written the ethics that
mr lambert is here
right i think they need to be looking at
what we recommend
coming out of this
well but they can turn around
um there's there's no reason why ned's
bill couldn't just be resubmitted the
way it is
he could do that he could do that um our
our
our report
for november
will say
generally that it shouldn't go
as it's written right just whether
between the lines or in the actual fact
it it should be changed in some way yes
yes it needs to change so then the
question is rather than wait for another
year um
how do
do we want to
as a committee or on an ad hoc basis
create
our our version of what it should say
i'm not sure i don't feel comfortable
quite frankly creating our version of
what it should happen because i'm
telling you well we basically are well
but no i mean i could go through this
ethics book
and and
make changes on probably every page
that's not a good thing i have no doubt
that that's not a good thing
but i think that we can make suggestions
of what needs to happen to any future
legislation such as
honing in on the definitions
put in exceptions for legislators
um in in future legislation but i think
recusal is an important part of this
legislation that needs to be there
somehow if we can say that
then that gives direction to the whoever
it is that's doing it because i really i
have i don't feel competent
not knowing the background in the
history and attended these meetings i
just don't
and any
changes that we may suggest um from what
i gather will
trigger
a rewrite and republication of these
rules and i think
the booklet if whatever we pass correct
will change maybe that's that's what i
meant to say okay i didn't know
but if we recommend this move forward
with the particular uh augmentations
that we've described right clarification
of definitions that the exceptions for
taxation and uh similar bep
real estate property taxes etc um
domicile issue
and balancing the ethics and the quorum
uh with recusal and making sure
we end up with a small card or an app
that we can give to these uh legislators
to make things a little bit easier it's
easier to said than done though yeah
it's much easier said than done i
wouldn't end up with the same just the
simple thing of saying a recusal on the
budget
or
an omnibus bill how do you
is it
one item in there that's a problem you
can
just disclose whatever address you know
maybe you know
it's a mayor's a simple majority you get
17 issues if the in there if you get
conflicts with three you're good to vote
is that how i'm well you can't
yeah but that's never going to happen we
shouldn't have omnibus bills anyway
that's my thing hello
but the budget is an omnibus bill well
it it it's
one it has turned into one
i understand and and this ethics bill
has to deal with the budget
we have no we i suspect it won't be as
omnibus like
i have no idea i don't think any of us
are going to believe it for a second it
doesn't matter it's it's
it the ethics rules have to deal with
an omnibus or a budget type bill and we
and and somewhere these guys or us
have to say what
what does the legislator do when he's
faced with that situation and maybe
if we put in there that the legislature
legislator
can in fact recuse and not vote on it
then perhaps the folks putting together
the budget will be more careful of what
goes in it
i like dreaming that's okay i like to
dream yeah um
any normal just saying um so i kind of
wish um
notwithstanding and
i appreciate you being here greatly but
because we would have been just sitting
talking to ourselves and lord
but ned gordon um
is a is a key player
in this and um
and i think
maybe
we understand
um in for september and say
we that
when we wrap this up
um does that sound right yeah that
sounds like it doesn't matter
maybe we could if we could take the
notes that were that were drafted by the
clerk and make sure that the
that the rest of the committee has those
notes and that
that ned has those notes so that he
could be prepared for
those kind of links to the video
and a link to the video
why are you because i will have to be
careful with the dates i've got some
major trips going here september is a
period oh i i may i said september yeah
okay
we only need it
by november first
okay and then it's in my lap okay
um
great i appreciate it again thank you
very much for all of your assistance um
any
comments questions or
or thoughts that you have that would
help us
um i hope i didn't make it more
confusing but i mean it sort of is that
way inherently so yes um there were some
other issues
do you want to just keep the bill
limited to i shouldn't say limited too
but only about recusal because there
were a couple of other
issues that the committee has in which
may have been something they would have
addressed in the senate from that
legislation no
um
the committee would like the ability to
admonish
respondents um following an initial
review
so i'm just throwing that out there yeah
totally different than recusal
um
is there any of this
in anything other than committee minutes
or no can we get a copy of those
committees
um
not we didn't get to that point no but
following
the next step in a complaint which is
preliminary investigation
the committee
can have an informal resolution with the
agreement of the respondent and then
they can admonish
there's been a whole lot of complaints
this past
year and a half
which are relating to legislator
misconduct particularly on social media
sites
and there's the speaker's
special committee which
handles some misbehavior issues
and on that the speaker can write a
letter of caution
which he's done
but the committee can't do that
currently under its
provisions for complaints
at the at the initial level of initial
review
and so the committee felt and they all
agreed
that it would be helpful to have that
tool
where they could admonish
at the first level
even without the respondents agreement
if they've done something that
doesn't rise the level of going forward
to
you know reprimand expulsion
or accenture but at a lower level i'm
just saying that something that is it is
it something less than censure yes
it wouldn't be voted on by the body it
would just be from the committee and and
so this presumably would come through
the special committee if the special
committee exists in in perpetuity here
it would come through that special
committee and be referred to
no well it could be no this would be a
separate that special committee can do
their own thing
but this would be for complaints the
ethics committee which are in their
jurisdiction yeah
um they could have the ability to
admonish a member
and then close out the complaint
i guess what i'm trying to find out is
could this complaint to the ethics
committee be running concurrently with
the special committee or is this a a
continuation of that process through
the
the special committee to the ethics
committee this would be separate for the
ethics committee okay
yep
just a quick thought
rather than putting in admonish
would it be
in our
interest to say something about review
remedies available to the ethics
committee
rather than us saying it in
so they so then they would handle that
under that caption review remedies
available
yes is that okay okay
cause i you know
the remedies already in this that you
have available already in here yes
okay um under
both the procedural rules and also the
statute if you go to page 28 complaint
procedures
and 29.
actually page at the top of 29
it talks about upon the completion of
the preliminary investigation which is
the second stage of a complaint
the first is the initial review and so
to get to the preliminary investigation
the committee needs to vote
by majority vote to take it to that
level
there you can have an informal
resolution and it can include
um
um actually it's not the first paragraph
sorry it can include um
7b
uh written advice or admonishment
remedial action so forth
so we could put in in
in our little game to review the
remedies available and make
recommendations okay and then you could
take care of that and whoever it is in
future legislation coming forward would
that be is that right
if we put something in our i don't know
i phased out on that say that again
please i'm sorry that's what
you wanted about admonishment and we're
looking at uh page 29 of the ethics
rules yeah under seven
they
for us toward it
put something in there it is a
thing i think we are making
recommendations well it does say
admonishment in here such informal
resolution may take the form of written
advice or admonishment yeah but if the
committee can't do it it can only be
done by the speaker right no the
committee can do this
what i'm trying to say is it can only do
it at a different stage of a complaint
and with the approval the consent
of the respondent you want to be able to
do it
upon initial investigation or something
initial review and and
circumvent the
the um
the approval of the
of the complaint
yes or the subject of the complaint
because the committee would the thought
is this whatever they did doesn't rise
to the level of going any further
why
why why would we ever
why would we ever have the consent of
the respondent to receive
because if they say no
it's a formal hearing which is like a
trial
and then through at the end of that
point the committee recommends to the
house or the senate
reprimand censure or expulsion
okay
got it
would i ask you about two more things
too yeah
in the booklet here
there's the harassment policy of the
general court
toward the end
beginning on page 51.
and it's not totally clear that the
committee has the jurisdiction to
enforce this
page
why did ned not include things like this
in here or is it just he was keeping it
limited to the request okay an issue
good too
this was passed by the facilities
committee
it was never voted on by the house
or the senate it's not a law
and
in the in the there is a piece of
legislation which requires that this be
in the ethics booklet yeah but there's
nothing that states this is the
committee's jurisdiction to enforce this
okay in fact
i'm sorry to have to refer you back
again
but
in
the
definitions of jurisdiction of the
committee on page
25.
there was a specific amendment
to jurisdiction of the committee a few
years ago
which limited the committee's
jurisdiction to not include rules
you know i think i i i think we can go
crazy with this right now i think you're
gonna have to do
i don't want to speak for the whole
people but i think you can opinion is
when we're doing this and having our
next meeting
in september or whatever october
whatever it is
we need to have this kind of laid out by
folks that come in with things that may
help us to make our decision in that
other session that we have
because for me to sit here and write
everything down like this september i'm
going to say you know
a short
well i almost think that one of the
recommendations might be
future legislation dealing with
abcd
so that correct so that it's it is i
don't i don't think we need
there's no advantage to having it added
to the existing
legislation that we're dealing with
i i think it would i'll certainly work
in a and it's been a fresh build in a
set well all of this has to be a fresh
bill but in a separate bill um
because you're right i mean i i can see
well
there's issues with all of those um
it's it's not entirely
i'd like to investigate why
um
rules
wasn't added to your authority i i'd
like to know removed you know all of
that kind of stuff i'd like to know
whether
the special committee that was set up by
the speaker will be
something that will handle the sexual um
discrimination
you know it it
i don't want to confuse what i think is
a good
start here by adding
i just wanted you to be aware of them
and then have a bunch of people recuse
themselves from voting on it because
they're
a whole nother story um
are we good
are there others on there but we
which is the beginning of the guidelines
principles of public service
what page page one one
i know i'm giving you a laundry list of
problems now but
the question is are those too vague to
be enforced and one member of the
committee in particular um
david hess
as david hess yeah has really um he
articulated this very clearly better
than i can do but
we have gotten all of these complaints
basically founded on principle four
and
it's
the ethics committee invited the speaker
and representative walner to come and
talk and and have discussion about
the fact that that we've got 11
complaints last year and about half a
dozen this year
on on based on this
and it's the committee's thought that
really
because a member of the public is saying
the legislator was rude to me
he violated principle four i'm filing a
complaint
and the committee says well
we're not sure this is really
something that we can enforce in terms
of a complaint because these are more
general and aspirational
in nature even though the word shall is
there
and so it's it's created some
bad
as you were speaking representative
about
the public image this is really i think
hurting the committee with the public
to the extent that this was known at
least from those who filed the
complaints which are confidential
that they file a complaint into this and
the committee says i'm sorry we don't
really have jurisdiction to help you
with that yes the legislator was rude
they did something on social media they
posted this that or the other thing on
social media or they yelled at you on
the phone or use curse words or whatever
all these things happen
and
we'll say well i'm sorry
so i guess the question is
what do policymakers want to do
with these four principles of public
service
tell them they should adhere to that um
it is
did um
did david
did david have a thought
on on four of
all of them he said they're they're all
all of them not just for root for
vagueness i think is the legal term he
used
just
take it out of the book
well he didn't suggest that but he
i guess making clear that just general
it's a wish list it's not a
it's nothing that can be enforced i
guess is what
i'm hearing go
that's my last laundry list
well
you know
i think that this principle of public
service is wonderful
but really what do you do yeah i mean we
take an oath to the constitution i mean
that's our hope
right we're not taking an oath to the
principles of public service
that's interesting we need
but if i understand correctly
the ethics committee can remove this all
on their own the guidelines can be
amended by the committee but it has to
be approved by the house and senate it
does
by statute no it's a unique process
this book is in your
jurisdiction
well yes guidelines
are um
page 27
um
i need a course on this book
roman numeral ii
and b3
yes
before guidelines and amendments become
effective the committee shall distribute
guidelines to the members i've read this
before
um specific guidelines or amendments
shall be brought to a vote and approved
by a majority vote of both houses
within a period of three legislative
days after distribution before they
shall become effective
i would make this almost
i would make this a separate bill and i
would make this
almost like we do
a cacr but you know it's a it is it's a
very
odd little
sweet spot of how to
it's just a this is a guideline huh yeah
ethics guidelines it doesn't belong in
guidelines though
the um principles
yeah
and complaints have been founded on
those too over the years
the ethics study commission looked at
this and previously ford didn't exist
and the other three used the word should
instead of shall
and so the commit the commission thought
that by changing that word
they were making these
um mandatory and something that the
committee couldn't enforce but the
current ethics committee and others who
have
presented arguments to the committee on
behalf of respondents
have stated that they thought this was
too vague to be enforced because it's
not giving the um
legislator any goal posts as to what is
acceptable and what is not
what would happen if you just simply
changed them back to should
that could be as a as a
um a goal
um
should aspire to yeah right
go forth and sin no more
bring that before the um
no that would if he changed that to
should we that would still have to come
before the house
how's the senate because you're changing
the guidelines and the guidelines
according here before guidelines or
amendments are become effective they
have to be voted on by a majority but it
should be a fairly
i would think it would be a voice vote
but
it's a statutory change i mean it's
changing the statute
um the principles are part of the
guidelines
oh that yeah 27 is 14 b3 statute
right
no we're not changing
we're not changing how the rule is how
the guideline is done we're changing
the guideline
so you're going to change this no no
you're going to leave this special boat
yes
yes you're just changing the guide
because you're changing the guideline
that that speaks to
which is this on page one
not changing how the guidelines are are
done you're changing
just the guideline
it's not a statutory change
should it be
statutory change
no
according to this it shouldn't
i didn't know if any future entity would
want to recommend that some something be
done there that's all
to get rid of that or alter it
all of the principles or all of the
the rule the principles
oh yeah
instead of just changing it from shell
to should or or the language
okay
all right i understand you you're i'm
glad you got it all right i got it you
got it
i'm feeling very best you're gonna be
the one that has to
deal with it anyways
all right
we good
thank you yeah i appreciate it um
i will entertain a motion for the work
session to end
unless i just
i'm getting
word from somewhere oh signature thank
you very much everyone appreciate it um
closing the work session on 15
uh 1368.
you